[Music]
here we go again the free games for
playstation plus subscribers for the
month of september 2020
have been revealed and you can download
these from september the 1st which is
tuesday
this one is a pretty good month if i do
say so myself so let's do this
first it's the original battle royale
game which started the current trend
playerunknown's battlegrounds which we
are lovingly called pubg
100 players parachute down onto an
uninhabited island
and fight to be the last one standing
landing with absolutely nothing we
pillage and loot the buildings to find
firepower pubg has been updated and
iterated upon for many years now
including many new maps
and good old cross plays here so if you
want to play against or with xbox and pc
players
that option is here the playstation
version of the game has specific
playstation items to unlock
including ellie's backpack from the last
of us and the outfit that nathan drake
wears
pubg these days doesn't hit the heights
of call of duty warzone or fortnite or
apex
but it's fitting to own the game and pay
homage to the first br to take over the
world
you should know there are frying pans to
use in the heat of battle
i challenge you to win using a frying
pan
and if you've ever heard the saying
winner winner chicken dinner this
is the game which started it if you are
not into competitive battle royale how
about
a straight up fighter and not just any
fighter street fighter 5
whether you play casually or online this
game is what the fighting genre was
built around
ryu seems to never get old and he has a
body just like mine
maybe not the fighting is easy to pick
up and play but for those who want to be
the very best you guys can look at
all your data and see every
invulnerability frame to become the
ultimate fighter
the story mode is a great way to play
and you'll see the characters you've
known for years
interact and it's a pretty good story
too on the flip side
there will be a ps4 championship on
september the 4th
in which you can win in-game items
cosmetics and a bunch of cash too
so whether you play for fun or to cause
as much damage to other players as
possible
street fighter 5 will be joining ps plus
on september the 1st
so there we have it what do you think to
those titles we can't run polls anymore
here on youtube so please let us know in
the comments how you rate the month
out of 10 i'm going for a solid 7 what
say you
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure i'll see you next time
[Music]
you